[Music]
in bad parenting news oh no which will
never be the biz hope not
all right submitter body comes to Abu
Dhabi I've been there I want a gold a
can you stop rubbing all the [ __ ] in our
[ __ ] faces Abu Dhabi [ __ ]
McDonald's we get it you know you're
cooler than us Wow
we get it you build sand castles there
no did you visit the soultaker nor
wanted you on a visit cool
there's a there's in Abu Dhabi there's
this island or this area called Yas why
yes and every time I yes
the yeah small Yas Island it was [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] is that where I came from I
don't know I don't think so but that was
[ __ ] awesome oh my god I got a young
neither came from a 13 year old valley
girl or a gay guy from West Hollywood I
want to say a gay guy probably someone
from Abu Dhabi we have a lot of fans
from that area yes surprisingly I did
like just like an impromptu hey come out
here just meet me real quick okay Wow it
was awesome there's so [ __ ] nice I
love them it's because they speak of
English oh man because I want to go
there and I want to ride like a dune
buggies like fast cars and stuff you can
do that over here to save because I want
to wear the Arabian like Prince outfits
oh yeah everyone always wears that when
they go over there so the person that
was guiding us there he's a local there
he said that's basically like men who
wear suits to work that's their formal
wear oh oh cool that's work so he wears
that to work that's dope I want to wear
that while I'm in a Ferrari or in a dune
buggy in the desert because I want to
feel like a old-school like Raider
in a caravan like going you know like
yeah with the squiggly sword yes yeah
Kolbe mjk Abu Dhabi trip I'm [ __ ] -
Robbie sick
you guys can't hold hands show any PDA
well you can but then people they were
made like yeah they're so worried about
it I know you can't have females but one
who guided us like he's kind of weird
about it but doesn't say anything that
yeah I like it over there I want to go
back
yeah I want to go to a place where women
are beneath men it's more I was like
enjoy a mother was asked by her fiance
to give up her son before they marry and
she's actually thinking about it well he
should man [ __ ] you and was this son
from another yeah apparently upon me not
that it matters I'm not seasoned I don't
know that's kind of shitty still hell
yeah well just like an adult means a
piece of [ __ ] yeah dad [ __ ] there's a
lot of shitty ass women who actually
dropped their kids for a man and there's
a lot of shitty ass kids that you want
to get rid of them but shittiest kids
aren't born they're made what the [ __ ] I
don't know sometimes they're born
people would say listening to his
stories he was a [ __ ] shitty kid but
when we really dissect it and get to the
meat of it all
he was just an under stimulate I'm just
very curious exactly but people could
say that you were shitty kids so what
happened tell em just you should kill
him not shitty just misunderstood I know
that's what I'm saying
but you see those nut kids are yeah so
this story was posted on this advice
blog called dear Wendy she wrote her
story in the advice blog so she's asking
Wendy for advice what a piece of Dux
yeah so here's what she wrote I mean 30
year old divorcee with a son
I have joint custody with my ex-husband
my boyfriend who is also divorced has a
daughter who is under the sole custody
of his ex-wife I don't know a piece of
[ __ ] progress I only get to spend time
with my son on alternate weekends and my
boyfriend doesn't see his daughter at
all my boyfriend already proposed to me
but one month after proposing he wants
me to give up seeing my son I did tell
him that my parents want to spend time
with my son too and they can only do
that on the alternate weekends I see him
he told me that he wants to go overseas
to work and meanwhile I can use this
period to think about whether I want to
give up my son for him I have thought of
giving up my son after we married but
how am I supposed to answer to my
parents what a [ __ ]
my mother has to
impression and my father has cancer I
don't want them to be sad knowing they
will lose a grandson she's more worried
about her parents loving the kid that
hurt herself losing a kid what the [ __ ]
kind of guy gives you that ultimatum
exactly insecure [ __ ] both pieces of
[ __ ] little bitch-ass [ __ ] I
think I think I would be the kind of
guys like you need a [ __ ] hangout
what you're kidding up your
irresponsible I don't know I feel like
that's such an undesirable trait yeah it
is
treat your guys's future cake Natalie so
she continues my boyfriend told me when
we started dating that he could not
accept my son and I know not all men can
I'm actually that's not amazing I'm a
[ __ ] yeah I'm actually prepared to give
up my son after marriage but my
boyfriend wants me to do it right now I
want to be with my boyfriend and yet it
can't bear to let my parents feel sad
because of their illnesses [ __ ] you you
piece of trash I also have mother's
guilt in me because my son loves me so
much you don't [ __ ] dump your
boyfriend
you're his [ __ ] hero you stupid dumb
[ __ ] should dump herself he sounds so
controlling like he's trying to cut her
off of every she sounds like an idiot
that [ __ ] makes the worst life decisions
ever - he's probably like you know what
we need to just start fresh you know
forget about the mistakes that we made
in the past I don't even see my daughter
anymore so I think you should start
fresh too and we should start fresh
together that's probably what he's
thinking because like I don't know I
think my son really loves me so I don't
know no no no baby baby shut up okay
we're gonna start fresh okay no more
mistakes just start fresh that's bait
that's probably what's happening because
there's insecure flux out there that
want zero like remnants of a past
relationship there's guys out there that
are so [ __ ] jealous they get jealous
of a non-existent past relationship yeah
my hag you [ __ ] you [ __ ] guys before
me how dare you you [ __ ] it's like
people have a life before they meet you
[ __ ] face till there be another
furniture insecurity and controlling
something stupid yeah that's that's
pretty stupid
like my ex he wanted to erase Isaac's
dad out of the picture with what like a
[ __ ] eraser
he wanted to be like no he's just the
babysitter I'm your real dad that's what
he would say to Isaac no no and I would
let him like an idiot you really what
was he paying for everything and
fathering him like a [ __ ]
cuz if you was doing some kc level [ __ ]
I could see that cuz Casey [ __ ] I'm
like dude if I was Isaac's dad I'd like
just call him daddy because Casey and
that's what you did he said that he
actually told us dope yep if really yeah
Casey murders is that daddy
Casey should be our kids daddy
yeah dad and then Papa should call his
real dad creator and then create [ __ ]
[Laughter]
too so it's not like you the bad father
either
but how would you guys respond to this
dude social service where do you live
secretary yes first of all you know what
that's a great idea where do you live
give me your dress I'm gonna send me
some nice stuff and then send social
services yeah
is she hot that question of would if she
was hot you can date her and ruin her
life and gets what you [ __ ] get but
she how old is that kid they don't
mention it just whatever I read is what
we have gotcha
I'm assuming he's little imagine if
she's like 60 something and the kids
like 30
she can't be she's got pencil edge still
oh it says she's 30 in the back advice
yes
still the kid is yeah could be could be
12 could could be five we don't know
she's considering that that's soft it
goes to show how stupid she is
so I don't think she's Shady I think
she's really dumb because she's
considering it and she's all she needs
advice so I think subconsciously she
knows it might be wrong does it gut
feeling she's like I think it's kind of
wrong but I need a dollar check yeah you
know he loves me so should I listen to
my boyfriend or my baby boy I don't know
Lonnie or Wendy's respond yeah yeah you
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] go Wendy go Wendy go
this is a Wendy said yeah no [ __ ] you
have Mother's guilt you're willing to
give up the little bit of time you have
with your son which is already a
depressingly small amount for a monster
of a man who doesn't see his own child
and doesn't think you should see yours
shame on you are you so lonely and so
desperate for a husband that you would
cast away your own child
apparently so please please get yourself
to therapy and figure out what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you that you would behave
in such an appalling disgraceful way I'm
not even touching on your parents that
you would use them and their illnesses
as a main reason to maybe keep seeing
your son occasionally speaks volumes get
help
don't even go up there be just jump off
a bridge [ __ ] it [ __ ] it this goes to
show like guys really just care about
looks like reputation no I mean like
guys would just [ __ ] anything there's
crazy [ __ ] that want men like it
doesn't matter I don't think any guy
goes I want I want a really intelligent
girl give her to me like it was later in
life that I said you know what I think I
really have to date someone that's
intelligent that was like in my late 20s
before that is I want someone cute yeah
I want someone that's fun someone nice
it's understandable people yeah [ __ ]
prank why do these people
oh no gas chambers there's so many
stupid people they're just having boys
baby babies it's just like there's one
girl my facebook I'm just like every
she's on her third one
oh my and it's just like you [ __ ]
dumb idiot yeah we control the gene pool
please Kelly can we force people to be
[ __ ] sterile please amen
hope you guys enjoyed that video but if
you didn't guess what you can directly
contribute to the articles that we
discussed just cruise on over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video click right up hey
[Music]